hasta hacer un bucle alrededor de la sala entera, y dijo:
"Bien, todos, sostengan sus pajillas".
Y lo hicimos. Y él dijo, "Bien. Ahora estamos todos conectados".
Y conforme las manteníamos, y respirábamos como uno,
sabíamos que no estábamos solos en este viaje.
Y aún tendida paralizada en la sala de columna,
hubo momentos de increíble profundidad y riqueza,
de autenticidad y conexión
que nunca había experimentado antes.
Y cada uno de nosotros sabía que cuando saliéramos de la sala de columna
nunca seríamos los mismos.
Después de seis meses, era hora de volver a casa.
Recuerdo que papá me sacó empujando mi silla de ruedas,
envuelta en una férula corporal de yeso,
y sentí el sol en mi cara por primera vez.
me impregné y pensé,
¿cómo pude dar esto por sentado?
Me sentí tan increíblemente agradecida por mi vida.
Pero antes de abandonar el hospital, la enfermera jefe
me había dicho: "Janine, quiero que estés lista,
porque cuando llegues a casa, va a pasar una cosa".
Y le dije: "¿Qué?" Y dijo:
"Vas a deprimirte".
Y dije, "Yo no, no Janine la Máquina",
que era mi apodo.
Ella dijo, "Será así, porque, ves, le pasa a todo el mundo.
En la sala de columna, es lo normal.
Estás en una silla de ruedas. Es lo normal.
Pero vas a llegar a casa y a darte cuenta de
lo diferente que es la vida".
Y llegué a casa y algo sucedió.
Me di cuenta de que la Hermana Sam tenía razón.
Me deprimí.
Estaba en mi silla de ruedas. No tenía ninguna sensación de la cintura para abajo,
conectada a una botella por una sonda. No podía caminar.
Había perdido mucho peso en el hospital
Ahora pesaba cerca de 36 kilos.
Y quería darme por vencida.
Lo que quería hacer era ponerme mis zapatillas y salir corriendo por la puerta.
Quería que mi antigua vida volviera. Quería que mi cuerpo volviera.
Y recuerdo a mamá sentada en el borde de mi cama,
diciendo: "Me pregunto si la vida será buena otra vez".
Y pensé, "¿Cómo podría serlo? Porque he perdido todo
lo que valoraba, todo por lo que había trabajado.
Esfumado".
Y la pregunta que hice fue, "¿Por qué yo? ¿Por qué yo?".
Y luego recordé a mis amigos
que estaban en la sala de columna,
particularmente María.
María tuvo un accidente automovilístico, y se despertó
en su 16º cumpleaños con la noticia de que era una completa cuadripléjica,
no tenía ningún movimiento del cuello hacia abajo,
tenían daños en sus cuerdas vocales, y no podía hablar.
Me dijeron, "Te vamos a pasar a su lado
porque creemos que será bueno para ella".
Estaba preocupada. Yo no sabía cómo reaccionaría yo
al estar a su lado.
Sabía que sería difícil, pero fue realmente una bendición,
porque María siempre sonrió.
Siempre estaba feliz e incluso, cuando comenzó a hablar de nuevo,
aunque era difícil entenderle, nunca se quejó, ni una vez.
Y me preguntaba cómo había encontrado ella ese nivel de aceptación.
Y me di cuenta de que esto no era solo mi vida.
Era la vida misma. Me di cuenta de que esto no era solo mi dolor.
Era el dolor de todo el mundo. Y entonces supe, al igual que antes,
que tenía una opción. Podía seguir luchando con esto
o podía dejarlo ir y aceptar, no solo mi cuerpo,
sino las circunstancias de mi vida.
Y entonces dejé de preguntar, "¿Por qué yo?"
Y comencé a preguntar, "¿Por qué yo no?"
Y entonces pensé para mí, tal vez estar totalmente en el fondo
es realmente el lugar perfecto para comenzar.
Nunca antes había pensado en mí como una persona creativa.
Era una atleta. Mi cuerpo era una máquina.
Pero ahora estaba a punto de embarcarme en el proyecto más creativo
que cualquiera pueda hacer:
el de reconstruir una vida.
Y aunque no tenía absolutamente ninguna idea
de qué iba a hacer, en esa incertidumbre
llego una sensación de libertad.
No estaría más atada a un camino determinado.
Estaba libre para explorar las posibilidades infinitas de la vida.
Y darme cuenta de ello cambió mi vida.
Sentada en casa en mi silla de ruedas y en mi férula de yeso,
un avión voló por encima, y miré hacia arriba,
y pensé, "¡Eso es!
Si no puedo caminar, entonces debo poder volar".
Dije, "Mamá, voy a aprender a volar".
Ella dijo, "Qué bien, querida". (Risas)
Dije, "Pásame las páginas amarillas".
Me pasó el directorio, llamé a la escuela de vuelo,
hice una reserva, me gustaría hacer una reserva para salir de un vuelo, dije.
Me dijeron: "¿Cuándo va a venir?"
Dije, "Bueno, tengo que conseguir un amigo que me lleve
porque no puedo conducir. No puede caminar tampoco.
¿Es eso un problema?"
Hice una reserva y semanas más tarde mi amigo Chris
y mi mamá me llevaron al aeropuerto,
todos mis 36 kilos cubiertos en una férula de yeso
en un par de anchos de overoles. (Risas)
Les puedo decir, que no parecía la candidata ideal
para obtener una licencia de piloto. (Risas)
Estoy sosteniéndome en el contador porque no puedo estar en pie.
Dije, "Hola, estoy aquí para una lección de vuelo".
Y dieron una mirada y salieron a hacer una rifa.
"Te toca a ti". "No, no, te toca a ti".
Por último, este chico sale. Va,
"Hola, soy Andrew, y voy a llevarte a volar".
Voy, "Excelente". Y así me condujeron abajo,
me sacaron al asfalto,
y allí estaba ese avión rojo, blanco y azul.
Fue hermoso. Me levantaron hasta la cabina.
Tuvieron que subirme al ala, ponerme en el habitáculo.
Me sentaron. Hay botones y diales en todas partes.
Pienso, "Oh, ¿cómo puede uno saber algún día que hacen todos esos botones y diales?"
Andrew, el instructor, fue al frente, encendió el avión.
Dijo: "¿Le gustaría hacer el rodaje?"
Es entonces cuando uno utiliza los pies en los pedales del timón de control
para controlar el avión en el suelo.
Dije, "No, no puedo mover mis piernas".
Exclamó, "Oh".
Dije, "Pero puedo usar mis manos," y él dijo: "Bueno".
Se fue por la pista, y aumentó la potencia.
Y conforme nos elevábamos
y las ruedas despegaron del asfalto, y volábamos,
tuve la más increíble sensación de libertad.
Y Andrew me dijo
cuando llegamos al área de entrenamiento,
"¿Ves esa montaña allí?"
Y dije, "Sí."
Y él dijo, "Bien, toma los controles, y vuela hacia esa montaña".
Y miré hacia arriba, me di cuenta de
que él estaba apuntando hacia las Blue Mountains
donde el viaje había comenzado.
Y tomé los controles, y estaba volando.
Y era un largo, largo camino desde la sala de columna,
y bien supe entonces que iba a ser piloto.
No sabía cómo podría nunca pasar un examen médico en tierra.
Pero me preocuparía de eso después, porque ahora tenía un sueño.
Así que me fui a casa, hice un diario de entrenamiento y tuve un plan.
Y practiqué mi caminar tanto como pude,
y fui desde el punto en que dos personas que me sostenían,
a una persona que me sostenía,
al punto donde podía caminar alrededor de los muebles
siempre que no fuera muy lejos.
Y entonces hice un gran progreso hasta el punto
en que podía caminar alrededor de la casa, sosteniéndome en las paredes,
así, y mamá dijo que ella estaría por siempre siguiéndome,
limpiando mis huellas digitales. (Risas)
Pero al menos siempre supo dónde estaba.
Así que mientras los médicos continuaban operando
y rehaciendo mi cuerpo de nuevo,
yo seguía con mi estudio teórico, y luego, final
y sorprendentemente, pasé mi examen médico de piloto,
y esa fue mi luz verde para volar.
Y pasé cada momento que pude salir en esa escuela de vuelo,
fuera de mi zona de confort,
todos estos chicos jóvenes que querían ser pilotos de Qantas,
saben, primero en mi férula corporal de yeso,
y luego en mi soporte de acero, mis overoles holgados,
mi bolsa de medicamentos y catéteres y mi cojera,
y acostumbraban mirarme y pensar
"Oh, ¿está de broma? Nunca va a ser capaz de hacer esto".
Y a veces yo lo pensaba también.
Pero eso no importaba, porque ahora había algo interior que me quemaba dentro
sobreponiéndose a mis lesiones.
Y pequeños objetivos me mantenían en el camino,
y finalmente conseguí la licencia de piloto privado,
y luego aprendí a navegar, y volé con mis amigos alrededor de Australia.
Y luego aprendí a volar un avión de dos motores
y conseguí el certificado de doble motor.
Y luego aprendí a volar con mal tiempo, tanto como con bueno
y conseguí mi certificado de instrumentos.
Y luego me dieron la licencia de piloto comercial.
Y luego me dieron mi certificado de instructor.
Y luego me encontré en esa misma escuela
donde había ido para ese primer vuelo,
enseñando a otras personas a volar,
apenas 18 meses después de haber dejado la sala de columna.
(Aplausos)
Y entonces pensé, "¿por qué parar aquí?
¿Por qué no aprender a volar invertida?"
Y lo hice, y aprendí a volar invertida
y me convertí en una instructora de acrobacias aéreas.
¿Y mamá y papá? Nunca han subido.
Pero entonces sabía con certeza que aunque mi cuerpo podría limitarme,
era mi espíritu el que era imparable.
El filósofo Lao Tzu dijo una vez,
"Cuando dejas ir lo que eres,
te convertirás en lo que puedes ser".
Ahora sé que no fue hasta que deje ir lo que creía que era
que fui capaz de crear una vida completamente nueva.
No fue hasta que solté la vida que pensé que tendría
que fui capaz de abrazar la vida que me estaba esperando.
Ahora sé que mi verdadera fuerza
nunca vino de mi cuerpo,
y aunque mis capacidades físicas han cambiado dramáticamente,
quien soy es inmodificable.
La luz piloto dentro de mí era aún una luz,
como lo es en todos y cada uno de nosotros.
Sé que no soy mi cuerpo,
y también sé que no eres el tuyo.
Y entonces ya no importa más lo que pareces,
de dónde vienes, o qué haces para vivir.
Lo que importa es que sigamos avivando la llama de la humanidad
al vivir nuestras vidas como la máxima expresión creativa
de quienes somos realmente,
porque todos estamos conectados
por millones y millones de pajillas,
y es el momento de los unirlas
y sostenerlas.
Y si queremos avanzar hacia nuestra felicidad colectiva,
es hora de que nos despojemos de nuestro enfoque en lo físico
y en su lugar abracemos las virtudes del corazón.
Así que levanta tu pajilla si te unirás a mí.
Gracias. (Aplausos)
Gracias.